Hey Youtubers it’s Charlie and this week,
Game Of Thrones totally went there.
We got to see a Bran for the first time this
season and a couple new characters from the
books and two really big plot events went
down.
And a quick reminder that round 2 of the giveaway
starts now.
All you have to do is be a subscriber and
leave a comment.
Because there’s so many WTF moments, let’s
just get right into the top 5.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
But Number 5 - Ramsay Snow takes Theon and
heads for Moat Cailin.
This is a little different that the books,
but essentially Ramsay is trying to get recognized
as an official heir of the dreadfort.
In order to do that, he has to take Moat Cailin
in the north.
It’s going to bring them closer to Theon’s
sister and her force of Iron Born, so it seems
like they’re setting up a big battle between
the flayed men and the ironborn later this
season.
Think of it as a slightly less epic version
of the battle that’s shaping up between
the wildlings and the Night’s Watch.
I thought it was interesting that Theon just
found out about the Red Wedding for the first
time.
And I have to give a bonus shoutout to the
hunting scene at the beginning.
Those two women, the one shooting the bow
and the one being shot, were the girls Ramsay
used to torture Theon with sex last season.
Number 4 - The Jousting Dwarves At The Purple
Wedding
Everyone had been asking me if the show was
going to use them since they were such a defining
moment of the wedding banquet.
But I had no idea and was just as surprised
as everyone else when they came pouring out
of the lion’s mouth.
As messed up as it was to degrade the dwarves,
did you see the looks of horror and rage on
everyone’s faces.
Even Tywin was pissed off.
But it was Lady Olenna’s face that was the
best.
Just pure daggers shooting from her eyes.
I didn’t see anyone that resembled Penny,
one of the dwarves from the ceremony that
has some dialogue in the book.
Let me know if you spotted her.
The music that played under all this was the
rains of castamere if you didn’t hear it
right away.
There were a few versions of it throughout
the wedding, but it was playing in the chapel
during the ceremony, when the singers came
out, during the jousting and during Joffrey’s
death scene.
I’ll say the flat out most disturbing moment
was when the dwarf was skull fuck*ng the wolf’s
head.
That was just awful.
Number 3 - Bran Wargs With The Tree And Sees
Everything
It was hard to tell but Bran was actually
seeing everything the weirwoods had seen all
over the planet.
That’s why he could see the north and King’s
landing.
He also saw a side shot of the greenseer,
who gave him instructions where to find him.
Everyone keeps asking me about coldhands,
and we might find out if he’s going to appear
next week.
I was also super excited to finally get an
answer about the dragon flying over king’s
landing.
Bran saw it as it happened in the past.
So I’m going to be optimistic and say he
was seeing on of the great Targaryen dragons,
maybe it could have been Balerion the black
dread.
He was the biggest in recorded history.
I’ll try to explain more about the Bloodraven
and greenseeing in my bonus video next week.
Number 2 - Joffrey Degrades Everyone at the
Banquet
It takes real talent to be that awful.
I was surprised he didn’t pick on Sansa
more, but if Tyrion hadn’t been there he
probably would have.
If it wasn’t clear, they were just trying
to show that Tyrion had the most reason to
want him dead.
Everyone at the feast saw him defy Joffrey.
Regardless of how Joffrey died.
Tyrion is taking the blame for now.
One of my favorite Joffrey lines from the
feast was “There has been too much amusement
here today”.
Yes, yes there has been.
and my number 1 WTF Moment - Joffrey Dies
If it wasn’t clear, he choked to death.
The poison was called The Strangler, because
choking and when it’s made it looks purple.
That’s why this is called the purple wedding.
Because Joffrey is killed with “purple”
poison.
The show is probably going to reveal the real
truth eventually, so I won’t go all CSI
and point out all the details yet.
The show wants us to think Tyrion did it,
but we saw he was confused when he picked
up the goblet at the end.
So he has no idea what happened.
Did you catch that shot of Lady Olenna when
he grabbed the goblet for Joffrey a few moments
earlier.
She was not staring daggers anymore.
The death scene itself was amazing, prolonged
and intense.
I didn’t count, but they cut back to his
face several times and the camera just lingered.
They really want us to understand that he
suffered horribly, which is good.
But the image is so disturbing that you have
a hard time enjoying the moment.
So now it’s your turn, let me know what
your biggest WTF moments were and what your
reaction to Joffrey dying was.
There was this really interesting thing George
RR Martin said, he mourns his villains just
as much as he mourns killing heros.
Just like you would mourn a real person.
He explained that as bad as they are, villains
serve a purpose in the story and once they’re
gone, they’re hard to replace.
So the next big question we need to ask is,
who will replace Joffrey’s role in the story.
As the most hated character.
I nominate Ramsay Snow, but write your own
suggestions in the comments for new WORST
character.
Overall the episode as a solid A, Game of
Thrones has the best sets and the best costumes.
And the music, the way they kept using Rains
of Castamere was so haunting.
Even if you didn’t know Joffrey would die,
the music just made you feel creepy and wierd.
Like the universe didn’t want this wedding
to be a success.
They did this really awesome thing with the
set design.
In every single baquet shot, there’s the
image of a lion in the background.
Wherever the camera turns.
My favorite one was the shot where it looked
like the Lion was eating Loras’ head.
As for character development, I love Ramsay’s
relationship with Roose Bolton.
He may be evil, but Ramsay still treats him
like a son and gives him a chance to earn
the Bolton name.
I have to say that when Ramsay and Locke talked
about cutting Jaime’s hand off, it was almost
a more evil moment than the dwarf skull fuck*ng
the wolf’s head.
Lady Olenna and Tywin’s scene just oozed
with foreshadowing, just two of the best actors
on the show.
Aren’t you wondering whether or not Tywin’s
going to have any fun before he dies?
Who knew that Cersei would be jealous of Brienne
despite kind of dumping Jaime last week and
aside from them I just love the direction
Bran’s character is going.
He’s slowly trying to just completely leave
his body so he can be whole again.
I can’t wait to see what his scenes with
the three eye raven are like.
Let me know what your final thoughts are on
the episode.
One of the worst villains on the show is gone,
but evil abhors a vacuum, so who is going
to replace him?
If not on the Iron Throne then somewhere else
in the story.
The Thenn’s seem pretty evil.
The King is Dead, Long Live The King.
So Q&A will post tomorrow, I’ll be picking
a random subscriber in the comments to be
the week 2 giveaway winner.
I’ll announce who in that Monday video.
And like I said, next week unless something
way more interesting comes up I’ll do a
bloodraven greenseer bonus video.
Right now click here for that Q&A and click
here for my bonus purple wedding video.
Just explaining it a little more in depth.
Thanks for watching, go hug someone you love.
High Fives!